les comédiens ont annoncé ce matin leur
possible installation au théâtre de la
porte saint-martin
dominique poncet une grève aussi dures
que celles ci la comédie française n'en
n'avait pas connu depuis 1972 il ya
maintenant près de trois semaines que le
rideau ne se lève plus le soir salle
richelieu responsable du blocage les
machinistes et tapissiers cgt qui exige
une parité de salaire avec leurs
homologues de l'opéra en tout une
quarantaine de personnes sur une
entreprise qui en compte 380 la
direction a fait ses comptes selon elle
le conflit lui a déjà fait perdre en
recettes 1 million 600 mille francs
devant le risque de déséquilibre
financier leur maison les comédiens
français ont annoncé ce matin qu'ils
allaient jouer ailleurs il s'agit du
public vaut quand même de nous
manifester et vis-à-vis des acteurs nous
nous devons de leur donner leurs
aliments et en particulier une troupe
qui depuis deux mois répéter un
spectacle qui ne pourra pas le le
présenter dans notre théâtre et il était
parfaitement normal qu'on trouve un
théâtre pour qu'il puisse avoir le fruit
de leur travail
sauf imprévu les comédiens français
devrait donc émigré au théâtre de la
porte saint-martin à partir du 27 avril
pour la création des femmes savantes
mise en scène par catherine hiégel les
cette décision d'aller jouer hors les
murs si elle résout en partie le
problème du public qui se heurtent
chaque soir à des portes fermées ne
règle pas le conflit interne
ce matin les grévistes faisait part de
leur amertume regrettons cette décision
qu'ils n'ont apparemment pas encore
prise définitivement mais nous la
regrettons car ça serait vide
richelieu de son âme nous avons demandé
à la direction départementale du travail
d'essayer de renouer la négociation
nous allons revenir avec son aide à la
charge le conflit risque de s'éterniser
il faut savoir qu'à la comédie française
les augmentations de salaire sont
décidées par le gouvernement et non par
la direction
cette année ces augmentations été fixé à
2%
pour preuve de sa bonne volonté et en
puisant dans ses réserves la direction
les a portés à 3%
aller au delà serait aller à l'encontre
des décisions ministérielles mais les
grévistes eux ne l'entendent pas de
cette oreille là